I'm curious because you mentioned
earlier as um you know your job to find
the money to
fuel the anime surely when the show
takes five years
that's a lot more money that we got to
get a hold of how do you kind of I mean
how do you convince people to be like
it'll make enough money trust me it'll
it'll work what's that whole I'm just so
interested about the financials of it
all because it seems like such a kind of
an industry that doesn't have a lot of
money but somehow it always just turns
up and it's like we'll figure it out so
a lot of Japan is not really uh legal
culture so it's a lot about trust yeah
worldwide so I mean we orange luckily
had a track record of making amazing
shows yeah right animation at least so
um we basically were building on that
trust working on that trust right
constantly um just saying that it's
gonna be okay
and so as a because I'm I don't know how
any of this works you know as a studio
that actually actually makes the show
how is it the studio actually makes
money from these shows is it you know
what kind of uh Revenue ways of getting
revenue is there for the two years uh it
depends on from it really depends on on
the show widely on how each show is no
okay um for Orange um the primary is
we're work for hire so we got hired by a
client to do one show okay okay that
makes way more sense I thought it was
like okay guys we gotta we gotta sell
this many REM figures oh we're going
broke this [__] all right crack open the
savings account boys like whatever
everyone pitching a thousand dollars all
right boys we'll make taking a ram
spin-off you know we've got to get those
figure sales up here actually you know I
always wondered how it all you know
because it seemed like it was a lot of
different rates holders and a lot of
different parties at play and it seems
like a really complicated massive who
gets what money and why there's so many
different things and wait why is RAM on
a Pachinko machine what the hell yeah
it's like a bunch of different things
going on it it always seems just kind of
like a yeah trust me yeah trust me it'll
be fine another approach a lot of the
time so how long does it take to produce
a single episode of anime let's say like
a single 20 minute episode of anime in
in your experience how long does that
take so um a normal production would say
like three months but that's not for
orange normal production right um in
Orange's case we actually uh make three
episodes about three episodes at once
right and then find what's the quality
line and then based off their make the
rest other episodes right so that first
three episodes is a benchmark maker what
do you mean by the quality line I mean
so like this is the quality Benchmark
that we're trying to set
well you set yourself a really hope yeah
I've seen that first episode yeah
yeah it's so high please
oh so you could be like guys pop the
brakes on this one let's make this
shittier we got to make 50 goddamn apps
we're gonna slow down I just like the
thing like how many times for every
single project I say we are doing better
than any other show so you're at least
your job guys make it worse please stop
this I just like to imagine like episode
one just like airs for everyone in the
studio to watch everyone's just sweating
yeah being like oh [__] we're gonna top
this yeah it does feel like when you're
you know when your older brother is like
smart you're like [__] sake man really
I look worse be dumb like I remember
like Dragon Stampede episode when it
opens on a scene where it's like
um it's like the spaceship is like
exploding and you see uh fashion nice uh
like flying out yeah and like whizzing
around and I remember watching I was
like God damn yeah
I suppose you you watched down you're
like this we got 12 episodes of this now
we've got to keep up to that was okay
that was okay yeah when I saw a 12
episode
um the when they were doing it I'm like
I messaged my uh everyone in the company
I'm like how are you doing this
it's like we're [__] boys I've noticed
now because there is so much anime being
made it's like more compete like
competitive than ever in terms of like
shows that you got to compete with
there's a lot more pressure to make like
episode one a standout episode to get
people's attention do you have that
thought mindset going into like
producing an anime that you have to make
episode one stick or land as soon as
possible or is that something that it's
not really thought about
it's I mean definitely it's a weekly
show so the first episode really matters
right
um also we in our mind for our based on
our successful experience with
landlessrius yeah is that first three
episodes to really really matter the
three episodes
was based on a movie uh the three
three-part uh I don't know the English
Trilogy no no uh uh how it's act one act
two oh yeah
so it's based on three act rules so the
first three episodes was the first act
right right from there it changes the
tone again right would you say that
Trigon was the hardest production you've
been involved with yes every single
production is always hard but it just
updates whatever it just gets harder and
harder and harder yeah how was uh
working on B Stars compared to Trigon
[Laughter]
Stars our animator took one week to do
one shot and Dragon stampy took three
weeks to one shot
[Music]
I mean I guess you know if you have to
animate clothes uh on characters and
Trigon versus
oh the face yeah because like I noticed
I'm not sure if this was always the case
but I definitely noticed in Trigun that
you guys lip synced the audio which
which I'm like you're not using like the
three frames of the mouth like that I'm
used to you actually like going frame by
frame and animating the facial
expressions as well which I I which is
one thing that like really stood out to
me yeah so how do so going going to be
stars then how was that pre-production
did you was there as much time put into
let's say the World building and the
vibe
um going into that production uh vista's
case we never um I mean the original
intention for our producing is that we
love B Stars yeah and um the whole the
producing team was that the first page
was there let's adapt this as it is to
animation so it wasn't that as hard as
that okay so was itagaki Sensei like
involve as much as like Nitro since it
was with beastuzzle uh in different ways
so in her case
um she wasn't as she used to and she
doesn't um she wasn't really familiar
first of all anime right so she was a
lot more female
um experience of film oh so for us um
our challenge was can we
um show this as a film to her and it's
just something passable to her that
explains so that's crazy the thing that
you would you like the whole way the
show is made is like just to kind of I
guess please one person essentially
that's so odd to think it's also odd to
think that she was never into anime
considering she's the daughter of
[__] the creator of buggy like you
think you'd be into an anime for a long
time right I guess I mean there was the
90s scrapple Bucky anime but yeah well I
I think that's part of the big reason
why like you know B Stars just I don't
know something about the vibe just
didn't feel like yeah it makes so much
sense because I feel unlike a lot of
manga stories out there the flow of B
Stars definitely feels more like a
live-action film than a standard manga
I'm just gonna say it's very weird yeah
this is weird is there ever a point
where you guys are anime and then she's
like you're like what the [__] is this
you're like oh my God what are we
animating like it's like okay boys I
don't know how to tell you this but we
can gonna have to animate a rabbit
having sex with a deer
they're just like okay
you're like all right let's just let's
just watch the rabbits so you're like
all right boys we're going to the strip
club we're going to research we're gonna
go on and on locations we did go to the
strip club
sorry to be
a dancing club
okay you guys right you guys taking
notes yes
there's some research purposes it's
because that there's a pole dancing
character I know yeah I watched it and I
was like what am I watching yeah season
one I could get away with saying I
wasn't a furry but season two it's just
getting harder to argue this oh no I
went into the anime already a furry like
I was I was already converted I just
need to ask why did you have to make
Juno so hot yeah uh honestly wait what
does that look what does that look why
did you have to make it so hot every
single character in that show is hot oh
no okay okay I will admit Lego C also
hot uh but do you know I don't know what
it is about Juno that awoke something in
me because she I think single-handedly
turned me into a furry I think there's
something wrong with my brain I can only
Envision the deer is called Stanley I
don't know
what is this it's Louie Louie I always
think of him as Stanley in my head
because
he would have been such a different
anime
Louis is also horses and yeah I just
like I remember that scene I think it
was like end of season one where we're
done right
[Applause]
without challenges
that scene where it was like Juno and
Louis together
like she's just on top of him I'm just I
could feel neurons just firing that's so
weird this sounds really anyone who
hasn't seen Beast I can only get Soul
wrecked
it could be a lot of this um what we do
is that it's Mo kept oh yeah yeah I was
going to go into that actually so I
assume that most 3D Studios don't do
mocap a lot of three Studios do mocap
but right they use it totally different
from away from us so how do you guys use
it as opposed to others so for us it's
only a reference so for example you know
how Pixar animators they act on camera
yeah and made their scenes yeah
basically we're just doing that in mocap
so all our animators are doing the
motion capture oh okay oh okay how
extensively is that used is that like
every scene or just uh every physically
doable scene so it's just regular just
talking like this right um our animes do
it but if it's like dancing fighting
martial art and stuff yeah we have
higher professional people today you
have to hire like a professional martial
artists oh wow oh that's cool or
professional motion capture yeah oh wow
how does that work so they come into a
studio one day and you kind of like
okay this is do you come up with the
choreography or do you get them to come
up with this like choreography usually
we hire someone to come up with a
choreography right right so how does
that read in a script versus how how
like what seeing why this took five
years yeah yeah
adding these steps on more than I
thought it was just some dude just
playing around with a model
I was just wiggling it around what the
hell is
people it's like I'm super curious so
like let's say in the script there's a
scene in Trigun bash fights a baddie or
something how much detail was in the
script that's the choreographer has to
work with to I guess make the make the
action scene action scene actually
relies heavily more on storyboard so in
the script it could be just like one
line at times okay okay I feel because
like yeah Vash is kind of I feel a
little bit different because his a lot
of his movements are just very animated
like to the point where it's almost like
it's it's the kind of comedic like
animated where it's like oh that's
clearly the movements of a cartoon
character or like an anime character
right it's like a lot of movements where
it's like a human couldn't possibly do
that kind of movement but it's
believable because it's not a real actor
you're looking at yeah kind of thing so
I feel that kind of movement would be
super hard for like a mocap actor to do
yeah yeah I mean I feel like especially
watching vash's like a lot of his
character is to do is in his animation
especially when he's like pirouetting
round bullets some yeah all that kind of
stuff
um so so in terms of like story like
storyboarding I guess uh going back to
the timeline of like an anime being made
so you you have the script and then does
the storyboard come after that and then
yeah and the scripts finalized we start
doing storyboard right so in our case um
we do something called pre-scoring after
that so instead of recording um most
Animes in Japan record after the when
they start doing animation but for us we
do recording before we start doing
animation because we want to make all
the pacing of the film before our anime
I guess that explains the perfect lip
syncing then because I was like that
would have been harder to make a film to
make a film yes it's weird how to get
better animation usually bring more
human involvement in the animation yeah
basically our concept is that how can we
use the experience but instead of
relying solely on people experience how
do we make that as a system so if we
could adopt that experience into a
system first then next project we could
use that system as a foundation to get
gain more experience